that's how i got hooked up with theo
because i was in mississippi filming ma
and um
one of the pas i was in my dressing room
listening to this past weekend so the pa
who came to my dressing room was like
were you just listening to theo vaughn i
was like yeah so it's like a niche thing
and he's like i know him and i was like
oh really like i'm a big fan of him i
saw him see him at the comedy store a
bunch of times i was like hook me up
with him um when i get back to l.a he's
like no problem so i went back to l.a i
shot this movie i had enough money in my
pocket where i didn't need to work a
restaurant job anymore
and he um that's when i started working
with theo and booking and doing this and
that so i was acting and filming stuff
while i was working with theo did you
like working with theo he's one of my
best friends in the entire world i love
him he's the funniest person he really
is hysterical he's got such a unique
there's very few comedians that are so
unique they're in their own little
place that
he just he just it's off the cuff it's
just like innately part of him the
things he says the things he does he
just shares them with the world